have you heard all the terrible news we
are destroying the planet middle class
is disappearing deadly Ebola outbreak
it's worse than ever before and yet the
cover of my favorite magazine since the
glass is not just half-full it's
completely full there is less war more
food we live healthier and longer lives
even work got good watching the news
everything's terrible they're wrong
reason editor Katherine mango war
we are absolutely wired to see a world
in which things are bad evolution wired
us that way if you are a caveman who
here's a little rustling in the in the
weeds and you say oh it's probably fine
and the other guy says it's probably a
tiger that's the guy who lives that guy
was our ancestors epidemic of mass
shootings exploiting nuclear war the
media make us more afraid this magazine
cover gets TV hosts right it is like
their hair is on fire but what's
happening in real life steady
improvement and often miracles children
get cochlear implants and for the first
time they can hear there are things that
in another era would have caused the
founding of an entire religion we made a
pot of logic patients walk again for the
first time in a decade
helping the lame to walk we do this as a
routine matter even food is better than
ever if I wasn't told that it wasn't
meat I wouldn't have know these are
people who want to make money by selling
you a burger that didn't hurt a cow what
about this constant complaint from the
media the middle class is shrinking
mostly it's because people are getting
richer people have moved up there are
more high income people than ever before
and fewer low income households here's
another reason article that reveals what
most other media don't report pestilence
war famine and death are all on the
decline you wouldn't know that watching
news program that's right and yet it's
absolutely true even the left-wing me
he admits it sometimes war is terrible
but over the past 70 years there are
fewer war related deaths there are fewer
Wars and fewer people died in those wars
even with the rise of terrorism even
with the rise of terrorism you are lucky
enough to live in a time where you have
you have never been less likely to die
that way you are probably going to die
of heart disease frankly but wait a
second suicide rates are up 40% among
white men lately life expectancy dropped
a bit still overall that is the tiniest
blip people are living longer healthier
lives
another reason story that contradicts
conventional wisdom is this one work got
good all I hear is that work is terrible
if you watch the news you would think
absolutely everyone in America is
currently laboring in an Amazon Factory
like crying while they fill boxes and
that's just not on average what work
actually looks like it did once look
like that a couple hundred years ago
work was dangerous it was very easy to
die at work and on top of that work was
extremely boring even for people that
had good jobs jobs are pretty
interesting now and they mostly don't
kill you and we should be grateful for
that development now the people that
reason aren't stupid they know there are
problems in the world so turn the
magazine over and you get the bad news
Venezuela threats to an open Internet
young people liking socialism socialism
or capitalism I will say socialism kids
love socialism if helping people is
socialism then I'm for it they have no
idea what socialism is mega Ward's most
upset about new restrictions on speech
the idea that what you can say on the
internet should be restricted I think is
the most poisonous of all her magazine
morons the constant growth of regulation
the state of Washington wants booster
seats for any kid who is a 4 feet 9
inches tall parents could be fined or
even in some cases imprisoned for
failing to comply with these laws a
congressman wants to regulate speech an
old woman is
because her dog leash is too long notice
a trend here everything that's bad is
politics everything that's good is the
market markets allow every individual a
choice
politics forces everyone to obey
whatever the majority voted for one
thing we try to do what reason is
describe why everyone should have less
power over each other anywhere they can
because people are gonna make mistakes
and hurt each other better that they
shouldn't do it with the force of the
state behind them bottom line there's a
lot of nasty stuff going on but life
does get better life gets better we have
the opportunity to look into a future
where those trends will continue if we
can just manage to keep politicians from
screwing it up